Adrien cadenas sur les bancs de
l'Assemblée nationale cela pourrait
bientôt devenir une image d'archives
accusée de violences conjugales contre
son épouse
elle doit être prise en considération on
doit entendre ce que dit cette femme
comme on doit entendre toutes les femmes
qui parlent aujourd'hui des violences
qu'elle subissent et puis la justice
tranchera et nous on est en train de
monter à une structure de lutte contre
les violences sexistes et sexuelles chez
Renaissance et justement on pose une
doctrine claire pour savoir à partir de
quand on est exclu et pour moi quelqu'un
qui a commis des violences conjugales
n'est pas quelqu'un qui est désormais
fondé ou apte à représenter la nation
française à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
un de son parti également certains
insoumis ne souhaitent plus voir le
député siéger alors côté tout le monde
est en train de comprendre qu'Adrien
catenaire peut nous faire beaucoup de
tort la France insoumise qui passe son
temps comme d'autres dans la nupais
d'ailleurs à donner des leçons de morale
à la terre entière devrait en tirer les
conclusions donc il pourrait au minimum
l'exclure de leur groupe nous prenons
acte des déclarations des grave qui sont
faites et donc nous avons pris
maintenant la décision qui ne participe
plus aux activités du groupe
parlementaire donc je considère que nous
prenons nos responsabilités voilà donc
pour répondre à cette question pour 337
contre 32 l'Assemblée nationale a
adopter la proposition de loi
constitutionnelle
aujourd'hui certains se lèvent et
brandissent des affiches pour dire
qu'elles sont pour le droit des femmes
tant mieux mais hier j'entendais autre
chose hier j'entendais parler de justice
parallèle dans petit consortium qui se
fera en huis clos pour entendre une
femme qui se dit victime de violences
conjugales l'Assemblée nationale parle
au monde notre pays la France parle au
monde et envoie un signal magnifique à
l'ensemble des femmes de notre pays mais
aussi à l'ensemble des femmes du monde
et députés des républicains eux se sont
divisés même chose au rassemblement
national au sein de ce groupe une
majorité a voté en faveur du texte
Marine Le Pen elle n'a pas voté absente
au moment du scrutin pour raison
médicale la position initiale doit
ressemble national ce n'est pas de
s'opposer au fait que l'ivgéron dans la
Constitution c'est que ça n'était pas
une priorité des Français je ne le sont
d'ailleurs toujours pas comme
prioritaire même si j'ai voté pour par
rapport à d'autres débats tout
simplement
[Musique]
d'ambiance en perspective à l'Assemblée
cet après-midi au cœur d'un débat qui
s'annonce où le une proposition de loi
LFI qui vise à interdire la tauromachie
on a auditionné notamment des
vétérinaires qui toussent reconnaissent
que ce que subit le taureau dans l'arène
et absolument intolérable que c'est de
la douleur que c'est de la souffrance et
d'ailleurs la loi elle-même le reconnaît
et il faut qu'il y a à la fois qu'on
prenne en compte nos spécificités nos
cultures locales
auxquelles sont légitimement attachées
certaines régions et beaucoup de nos
compatriotes et la condition animale la
sensibilité qu'elle éveille en
particulier chez les jeunes générations
dès qu'on est dans l'invective ça marche
pas je le dis très sincèrement donc il
va pas y avoir d'interdiction demain
c'est très curieux la sortie du
président de la République
c'est le Parlement qui doit se prononcer
ce sont les députés qui votent
aujourd'hui sur les députés qui vont se
prononcer sur la poursuite ou non de
cette de ce que j'appelle je n'hésite
pas à lire une barbarie
pour former un torero sur le bien-être
animal
un moment pour maintenir la corrida en
prévoyant une piqûre contre la douleur
[Applaudissements]
amendement pour que les corridas ne
puissent pas se dérouler lorsqu'il fait
plus de 40 degrés à l'extérieur voilà
comment vous travaillez fric Caron
retire donc son texte le député de la
France insoumise était à l'origine du
projet de loi sur l'interdiction de la
corrida la semaine dernière à l'aéroport
JFK de New York d'administration de la
sécurité des transports a publié sur son
compte Twitter une étrange découverte
dans une valise passée au rayon X un
chat vivant se cachait à l'intérieur on
considère qu'il faut reposer le débat
dès demain dans des meilleures
circonstances en déposant une nouvelle
proposition de loi qui cette fois-ci
sera transpartisane puisqu'on au moins
cet homme nous aura permis de constater
qu'il y a bien des députés dans tous les
camps qui soutiennent l'abolition de la
corrida l'animal ce serait glissé dans
le bagage en échappant à la vigilance du
voyageur heureusement le chat va bien et
a pu regagner son domicile